Hello Everybody!
My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Resident Evil 7.
If you thought the evil ended there,
there's so much more to this story that you need to learn about,
and it's all contained in banned footage from the Baker Family Farm
So! And there's also other--
I don't know,
Silly? Kinda games?
That are 'Ethan Must Die' and then 'Jack's 55th Birthday' Party
Which is like..
'It's Jack's birthday, but he's not interested in presents.'
'It's food he wants,'
'So find some for him as fast as you can!'
And that sounds disgusting!
So I'm gonna go with the "Banned Footage" first
I may not be able to get through all of this in just one go
but, I'm gonna see what it is
Reporter: "Many residents, in so--"
*sound cuts off*
(Incoming Spoop Collage)
"Why are you doing this--?!"
(Grunting)
(Eveline laughs)
(The lighter flicks on)
(Heavy breathing)
"Look at all the pretties my little girl has given me!"
Ewww
That's not a good gift, ma-ma
Okay,
So this is all of the Banned Footage
Those are like 'extra' games to play
But this is legitimate to the story, as far as I know.
So! Where do I start?
Do I start from Nightmare?
Do I start from Bedroom?
Do I start from 21?
Do I start from.....
Daughters?
*reads* "Experience the beginning
of the Bakers' tragic story"
Now, there's two volumes to this
and I don't know if there is a correct order to go in
in relation to the two volumes.
They were both released on PC
where I had my save game
at the same time.
So since this says 'The Beginning'
I'm gonna go with this one.
*Stutters*
You know with my luck I'm probably going about it backwards,
Which is how I've done pretty much everything in my games
(reading screen) three years ago the baker were like any other family
They had just finished a family dinner
Listening to the rain drops hammering against the window panes as they ate
A moment of peace and quiet
Their last for some time
And so we begin..
'Daughters- Last night Spent with my Real Family'
Again, I don't know who recorded this.
Oh!...ok..
(Derp)
Hello! (Laughing)
Great!
Cool!
So people were searching for the ship
Oh, Jesus!
I thought I was just watching a news story for there..
Huh.
So who am I playing as?
Who am I?
Wait, who am I?
I can barely remember the names of 'em.
Am I the daughter?
I'm.. pretty sure I'd be the daughter then.
*Chuckle*
This is so weird..
So weird..!
They look so normal!
Everything's so normal!
He's just messing on his phone!
I.. I ju--
This is so weird! She's not covered in bugs!
10/26 Anniversary...
They seem like such a loving family!
Alright, I'll get it Marguerite!
MOM, I-I mean
Cause I'm Zoe
(sighs) Alright then,
Good night for soup indeed,
(Mark takes it all in)
God! I need to wrap my head around this.
Also, I wanted to mention that some people pointed out
this might actually be before the zombie outbreak in Raccoon City.
Uh, I-I don't remember if there was an official source that said that,
but I might be willing to believe that too.
So... But either way, what I meant was, like, this is a good launching point
for the rest of the series. Because, this just opens up so many
more possiblities for Resident Evil.
If they're starting over, I applaud them.
Because this is the best way to start over.
I love this game.
I still love this game.
And this is just... scary
(Reads onscreen text)
Huh. I don't know. How would I know? I'm just Zoe.
Can I even go down here?
Dat's weird.
Why can't I go down here?
Yeesh... I don't know if I should go down here.
Hello?
This might be a dumb idea,
But...
I've got nothing better to do with my time, might as well explore.
Yeesh, weird..
Oh, hello. LOCKPICK!
HEY! That's good!
Wow, good for me!
Ey, good for me!
I did that! I did that thing!
I did a thing! I found a thing,
Okay. But, I got a change of clothes.
I'm assuming that means, that may-
I'm so bad
I gotchu..
Means that, uh
Oh, what's her name
I have no idea. I'm completely blanking on it.
Ah, well, it doesn't matter.
I'm gonna get her some clothes,
Then I'm gonna find out her name again soon enough..
I wonder where she went..
Oh, good!
This isn't filled with black pus!
Great!
And it's SO weird to think
that they wanted to run
a bed and breakfast,
--Can I open this?
Oh, hell yeah!
Secret?!
SECRET?!
BULLETS?!
Small Component..?
Okay?
I have that now..?
Don't know what that's for..
..But I got it...
Okay, so where was this girl..
stationed...
Huh
Helloo?!
Aw, this is where--
Quote Unquote, "Grandma's" Room was,
But now we know that it was not Grandma's room.
No, no, not indeed..
Hello?
Ah, nothing!
Goooood
No one has cleared up the dishes
I don't know whose room this is..
Okay, whatever.
Why's that yellow..?
They usually signify something...
Nails look loose
Okay!
Yeah, I don't even know why I'm exploring! (Chuckles)
I uh, I'm in the mindset that I need to explore,
and find resources, to be able to survive this,
but uh..
Maybe not...
Hello!
..Okay...
Bye daddy!
I guess..
Oh, this is not gonna be good..
Hello!
How are you doing?
Oh, do you need some clean clothes?
*Fake Scream*
(Eveline giggles, the door creaks open)
Oh, okay...
Lighter?
Oh, good thing i have that!
Woahh.. Oh, that's weird...
Oh, that's really weird!
Okay!
American Football!
Daddy!
Has she infected everybody yet?
With her.. evil.. goopiness?
Daddy..
Daddy...
Oh, no, it's.. blocked off....!
DAAaad...!
DAAad!
Dad..?
I don't know..
Not in here, obviously..
Alright then..
(Thumping noise from somewhere in the house)
Okaay...
Mom!
Lucas..
I don't think this is very
Goo--ooohh, heyy..
Oh, hi! Lucas, what's goin' on..?
Lucas?
Am I not worried about this? Ok.. here we go
Say nothing if you're okay..!
*muffled sound of someone talking*
*scary intense music*
Someone upstairs? Is that a sign?!
Am I supposed to go up here?
Yes, no, maybe so..
Tell me now, tell m--
(Loud noise)
All are welcome....
Mama..?
Mama-Bugs...?
I DON'T WANNA SEE..!
I DON'T WANNA SEE-- OH, MAMA--
Jesus!
Alright, we gotta do an (cough) exorcism, or something,
Holy SHIT....
Well, Marguerite's sp-seen better days..
Oh, I just opened this, why do I gotta open it again..?!
Just gimme the goddamn rope, I know where it is..
I know what it is and I know where it is..
Oh boy...
Ah, yes, rope!
That would be..
That would be nice to have..
Thank you..
I'M ON MY WAY!
I've got.. ROPE!
Whatever good that's gonna do..
Good thing I'm not in a hurry, or anything..
Eugh..
Ah, not at all..
I'd uh, never...
Uh..
I-I got you rope..!
I got you rope!!!
I got you rope!!!!!
I-I got you rope..!
I didn't know if I was supposed to turn and run away!
Am I supposed to fight?!
Hey, hey! --wOAH-HEY, WOAH, HEY, WOAH!!
Okay..
Alright then...
Oh, goody..
..Great, I failed--
Oh, I WAS supposed to run away,
OH,
I was, okay, I didn't..
I didn't know..
(Reads on-screen text)
WELL
I didn't know that!
*fake laugh* Ha! Ha! Ha! Ha!
Well, not for me, huh?
O-oh, woah, shit,
Okay, that didn't work out--
What I gotta do is,
This one's loose, this is why this was
painted yellow--
Oh, I don't have--
I-- The fork,
AH, shit--
OH have you?
Oh, that's good to know..
Oh-well, I-I don't wanna keep you
waiting,
s'all *mumbles*
Okay, alright,
Well, this is a weird stand-off,
I'm gonna go this way,
And hopefully find somethin' else that I can use,
To uh, get away from you..
In the meantime, I-I'm..
..Kinda screwed..
Hup..
Bam! Got it, okay--
So now that I've got that tied off..
I'm going to..
Get the fork,
And I'm going to..
Use it--
No thanks, I'm okay--
I'm gonna use this to pry off this..
..That works, for some reason..
Alright come on hurry
Lets go a little faster......
Little faster would be nice?
Expeditiously would be gewdd?
I could of just pried that off with my hands...
Ok which way out do we go...
This way--
That way--
I dunno
*Lucas shouts with pain*
Ok.. i dunno whats happening to Lucas
But Lucas isn't having a fun time down there....
Oh..ok
How did Lucas get upstairs?
Uhh
Ok
Thats not fun...
EHH I don't wanna accept her gift----
Okkk imma scadattle away
Huh?
Oh hi mom....
OH MAMA---
Mama no thank you.....
MAMA NO thank you!
(Zoe heavily breathing)
Am i supposed to go through this door?---
I gotta go downstairs--
I don't wanna little sister--
NOO
I don't know what your doing--
What are you doing?
You don't see me HUH??
How could ya?
Too smart...
....Too elusive..
Nope, no she is not...
No, she is not
...a sweet little thing.....
She's the opposite of that...
I unlocked it good
HEY MOM
OH HI MOM!
Ok
GO WHERE?
I dunno where!
I don't wanna look at this right now.
EUGH
I dunno where were goin
I think this is the key to the car?
Maybe I can take it and run away?
ok I wont do dat
EAGH oh
HEY oh this Ain't good
Imma go through here and then I'm gonna sneaky away
OH this is why I could go through here
Im so-Im so in a hurry
U dont know where this leads out!-U have no idea-you've never seen me as a child! you don't know anything about me
*Dad laughs crazily*
Dads a- Dads feelin happy. Good. I should go back up and give him a hug
ok...
alright sneaky-sneaky
Ok so i cant do anything with that
ok.. Do you see me?
Ok pops
Are yo-DEEDELYDEEDY
Ok so..
AWWUGH COME ON
Open this again
Get in there...
U DIDNT HEAR NOTHIN!
NOTHIN
WOAHHEYOHOHOHOHOH ok hopping in!
OH were not gonna make it, I know that for a fact but it feels good to just hop in and feel like I've accomplished my goal
Any day now!
Oh hey.. Hows it goin?
NOT REALLY
*sigh*
Great!
WHAT!?!
REALLY?
(Mark reads the on-screen text
OOOOOOOOH
So it must have had something to do with the items i was picking up throughout the thing!
So the little red piece from the lockpick that i found...that must go to something!!
And then obviously the car probably isn't the smartest way to go out...
Ahhhhh, Okay...
So what I proooobably could have done........
Ooooooh
Okay so, I was very close!
actually
The only thing i didn't try to do-and I didn't even think about it- Is get up in th-the attic area from Lucas' room because there's a secret in there
And I actually saw all the pieces!
When I started this out, I saw that Lucas was putting in his pin number into his phone.
I didn't think anything of it other than it was done really slowly, I did not know that was a piece of it!
So I'll be right back- Right back
Ok, sooo i gotta pay attention to this code, I can't remember what it was.
Ten-nineteen,  ten-nineteen, ten-nineteen, ten-nineteen
Ok 1019 that's very good!
Ta-daaaa!!!
*sings victory song*
Small component
hmm *reads screen*
Oh, it could be a button
It does look like a button!
OK so with this...
I beliiieve that's all I neeed
Ten-Nineteeeen
Yadayadayada- Yupdee
And then it's just do as I normally did.
ROIIIGHT?
I got it-Ya I was looking at it right there it even showed it, I did not pay attention to that!
Ok so I'm gonna put this right here, oh I cant put it there yet OK
Soo..."There's a hole in the trophy".
So if I put that there.. AND THEN THERE WE GO!
TADAAA
Ok so is there anything else here that I need?
SO up here-I DIDN'T EVEN THINK Of THAT--I didn't even notice that!
I would have tried that if I had even registered my brain, but I wasn't looking for it. so..
This goes to SHOW you gotta pay attention to these things-
I mean there were lots of secrets that I missed in the normal game and lots of things I overlooked because...
Whenever you do a lets-play and you go episode-to-episode,
there's time in-between each one
and you just forget, gaps in your memory
*reads text onscreen*
Well that's not very nice... That's not very nice at all
Ok-I got it. Boop
aaaaaah
whoopsies!
Boop
uh, 1019, I believe
boink
Boop!
Yaaay
Alright whaddwegot--
"the FUCK YOU list"
*reads onscreen text*
Red box on the veranda..
RED BOX ON THE VERANDA, is that the--the walky, slopey, porchy thingy?
so
he must have something in that
VERANDA
that I need.
So that must have been the clue, it can't have just been NOTHING.
That muuust have been a clue, right?
That had to have been.
There's no other way it wasn't a clue
Booo! Okay
Red Box!
On the-Woah
Holy Shit. That-
That was slow. AHH!
YEAH!
OKAY!
RED BOX
Okay, cool!
Throwing all my shit, in the red box.
Oh-urghhh
Fuck is that?
Ohhhh
Ohhh!!
OHHH!!!
Okay, so then I would be able to get out through the front door? Question Mark?
Yes? No? Maybe so?
I think so
Can I get back?
Can I get back, please?!
Please! I want to get back.
Alright
So now-
I've got the Dog Head relief
which means that when I go
I'm not gonna get the key from "Mama"
I'm gonna go through the front door with the dog-head relief
and then be able to get out that way.
Right?
Okay - BYE LUCAS! Have fun...
Maybe...
Maybe, maybe
Please tell me there's all the other dog reliefs here...
Yes, there aaaare!
Open up, please!
Open up!
Wooh! Away I go!
It is dark out here.
Aye yei yei
Okay
So..
It might be real.
Get out to that trailer, which was your home in the game
which I guess I didn't even realize that I probably needed to go to...
Help!
Help- 'cause I also saw the note in the beginning that
the other lady is stored here-
there she is!
Eugh, "talk about creepy" - no joke.
Yeesh
Okay?
So...?
"Reads text on screen"
Okay, so...
*reads screen*
So...
Eyyyyyy!
How's it going, Eveline?
My name's Zoe.
Haey!
*Eveline laughs as Zoe grunts in panic*
Okay?
*Zoe gasps*
Oh, no
Hi, Lucas!
Hiii!
How's it going?
You so scawy.
You
Okay, so that's really weird...
*reads screen*
Well, THAT is
fascinating...
FASCINATING!
*posh voice* Very fascinating!
I like it alot!
So, um...
I'm not gonna end it here
I wanna get through at least 2 of these,
uh, in one episode
because I don't wanna just, like, stretch it out to four episodes
and then that'd almost be the entire length of the entire series.
So I'mma skiddaddle right into-
Woah, I didn't even read the options there
*reads screen text*
I didn't read the rest of that, but okay
Didn't need to
*reads screen*
Can pain make you smart
Oh boy...
Hoh boy...
HOH BOY
That's not...that's not good
Haaah boy
Ohhh...hey, good, hi
Oh, good!
I see you
Okay
Probably
Cool
Yaaaaay!!
Hoh
Eugh
Haheeha, okay, alright
He-hey! I don't like this game
Ohhh
Weelll, could we just play blackjack?
How do I play?
Maybe
Once or twice
Okay?
Nope
So...oh
Ah, okay
I think...
The odds are in my favor
I'm not an expert at blackjack but I know enough
that 13- I think you draw a card.
Logically speaking.
Here we go!
Good luck.
oh no
Oh! That makes it easier.
Oh, good.
They're numbered 1 to 11 and we share the same deck...
There's no doubles, he's already got a 10
I've already got a 9
So, the odds are...there's a 1, a 3...
5, 6, 7
8...
There's only 6 possibilities
out of the 11 cards
that it's not going to be me over.
The- in my mind, we're playing a very perverted game of 21
so i'm thinking...
I'm gonna...
If he's gonna stay...
It's probably who's closer to-
I'm - give it! Give it! Give it! Go for it.
Yes!
That...is shitty...
I hate that, I hate this.
You'll stay, huh? You'll stay, ah, you're an asshole.
I don't like you!
'Cause there's no way
there's no way
There's every way, c-co, he could have a 3 under there..
Okay, he could have a 3...
Or a 5...
Or a 6 under there.
AAAGH
I'll keep this.
Ho boy...
Aww, come on!
NOOOOOAGH!
Great game! Love this game! Love it a lot!
Love this game a lot...
Oh boy...
Oh boy
7 and a 1
Oi
Of course you'll stay!
Oh, you're gonna stay
Hit me
UGH
Alright, well...
Well this is great, huh?
This is FUN!
Geeze, COME ON!
Man, this is set up-
OWIE! OW MY HAND!
OW, it hurts a lot!
UHHHHH
It's not like I'm doing anything wrong here
Guess I coulda hit on the last one, we'll see
Yeah, let's just keep it going.
Uhhh
Okay
This is better
But he's got 10
but...I'm not gonna do it
I'm gonna stay right where I am
Oh, that's a 6! OHHHHH!
OHHH!
I mean...I'm sorry, but..
Okay
ah
The game's interesting, 'cause now it's all even
Oh, boy, this is a fun time
HIT ME!
He's gonna stay with a 3 and a...?
At most he could have 14.
You're an idiot, at the very most you could have 14.
Alright, I'll stay.
Alright, you're dumb!
And I think this is set up
for both of us, to lose a lot.
Yup
Good ole Clance!
D-did that kill him?
Nah, he's breathing
Yup
Okay!
HMM!
Wish I could have won that with all my fingers.
Okay...
OH!
It's a taser!
That felt zappy
What do we do now?
Alright
Crank it up to 11, let's see what happens
Okay
Oh
*reads text*
Oh, okay
OHHhhhhh
Ahhhh!
Ahh
This is a fun game!
Thank you!
Thank you Lucas I feel good about this
Okay, alright!
Ahhh!
Alright, okay!
Let's see...draw me!
Give me a draaww
That's pretty good!
AH!
He might have 18
He MIGHT
YEAH!!
NOOO!
What a douche!
Hebelelelbbubrrrblubur - OWIE!
Ouch-kabibbles
Alrighty then?
Can I get another trump card?
I'd like that, that'd be nice
Ooo, thank you!
I'll take that!
Okay, 6 and 5
Same situation I was in last time...
At least I know the 6 card is not on here.
Ooh
Well, that's a little rude, don't ya think?!
Gimmie a good one- whoah!
Hey!
Alright, I feel pretty confident about this, but I'm gonna make him bet up.
Take a bet- I wanna end this!
I want you- JUST DIE OKAY?
Alright, I'm not 100% confident
to be able to use both of those
but I'm pretty sure I got it.
Pretty sure I got it.
HEEELLL YEAH!!
You didn't even have any cards at all!
Aw, sucks to be you!
Euhh!
Aw man, euhgh, that does not look good.
Eeeegh.
OW!
Ow!
Sure can, buddy-boo!
I'm fine, don't worry about me, I'm strong
I got strong lungs and organs that aren't melting.
*Burps* It's all good!
Okay- HIT ME! HIT ME!
ohhhhh
THAT'S a good card!
That's a da- that's a good card!
Aw, but did that mean that he just got to...
21?
Naw, it's no way!
That- there's no way that was that way because...
most- more than likely
that was just the only trump card he had
and he used it because it was gonna help him
So I'm gonna keep the current hand.
Because by math, he can't have 21
Me! It's me!
Clancy!
Uh-oh!
Oh,uhuh, eheheh, euueueueee!
*creaking door sounds*
Heh
Ah, geeze...
Ah, geeze!
Ohhhhh boy...
Ohhh boy
Ohhh, Clancy...
*clanking sounds*
Ohh!
Oh, Clancy...
WOAH! HEY! WOOoo
Oh, I- I know all about Mr. Saw!
Great!
Okay!
OOHH BOY!
Greeeaaat! I love this!
*chuckling* Geeze!
HOOOH BOY...
Oh boy, at least I'm getting trump cards.
Alright
Just give it, give it.
You know? Just give it over
Hit me, come on.
Hit me. That's a good one!
I like that one.
Well, shitty-dicks
YEAH!
*chuckles*
Now what you got me- "Love your Enemy"
*reads text*
Oh!
I don't know what that means?
Why would I use that?
Okay, what happens if I use this?
Because he might have 21 in there
What I'm gonna do is...
I'm gonna use this
'Cause if he has 21...
Well, if he didn't have 21, he does now, okay, that's...
shitty for me, alright I did a goof.
I did a righteous goof.
Let's see...
I got 10, 13...
I could get 21 if I- he doesn't have any of these cards.
Okay?
Okay.
HEEYYY! We both lose
But at least...I don't know what that means in this scenario
Okay, whatver.
Dammit! I'm an asshole.
God dammit!
I wasted all my trump cards!
OHHHHH boy
HEYY!!!
Hey, I didn't think I was gonna win!
Cool! Okay, so if I win this next one, I win!
Uh, I get to walk away scott-free with no punishment to my name!
I know that...that's true.
That's gonna be true.
That's definately true
I believe it to be
This is great! Great, I love start-
*sigh*
Oh no!
Ohh no!
OH NO!
OHH NOO!
OHHH NOOO!
Oh!
Oh No!
WHAA?
*Lucas laughs like a lunatic*
Oh boy.
Well...
Uhhh.
Hoh boy
Ahh
Well this...
This seems to have screwed me.
HIT ME!
Somebody hit me!
Well, I guess- I guess this is just the way it is then?
God dammit! I didn't-
I DID NOT!
You gotta be kidding me
Yeah, I know I'm dead.
Explain to me how I'm supposed to be able to beat that?
OHHH, I was supposed to save-
I was supposed to save the "Love Thy Enemy" for that one!
Ohhh, got it-
How would I have known?
Okay, hurry up, I gotta get through this.
So...
what I can do is "Love They Enemy"
"Draw the best bobbidable card..."
but if they're already draw the best possible card
then they're at 21
So this'll make 'em
Go over
Ha!
HUUH??
WHAA?
Wha? WHAAAD DA HAAEL!
I'm. Good. I'll. SCHTAY!
CUZ I KNOW WAD I'M DOIN' DERE!
After one death...
shon of a-
I'm ending dis
Wait- how in the world was he still alive?
What the hell?
*recorded applause*
Great!
No
Great...
What was that in the- what was that in the image?
Oh boy.
Well, anyway
So I unlocked some game modes which must have been- ohhh!
Rewards?!
Hoh BOy!
OH BOY, I've done none of these!
So anyway...
That is all the time I have for the Banned Footage DLC for Resident Evil 7
but I'm gonna get to the next part of this very soon.
I probably won't be doing them everyday like I did the main series
but they will be coming very shortly.
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always I will see you...
In the next video!
BUH BYE!!
*outro music plays*